that's not the plan
the music thing you and ddg were
supposed to come out with an album I
heard a lot of the music and it was it
was it was delicious you guys are
battling each other yeah is it ever
coming out I hope so
um
think about artists sometimes they'll be
on their own path day on their own
Journey
it's hard to get on the same Lane
because I look at you kind of
made it possible
not I don't want to say that because ddg
is a talented kid no but yeah no but he
definitely started something will you
helped validate him as an artist and not
a YouTuber with moon marketing Calabasas
yeah absolutely that's the truth yeah I
think it would just be dope just because
I've heard the record y'all got I got
some [__] I like that back and forth
where they're battling because it's
crazy because they say that me and him
should go back and forth
you know which I think would be crazy
too but
I'm not really an artist type like I
[__] with people I'm filming like for
instance with her I [__] with her so I
mean she's obviously what does that mean
so it's not about the music
it's not about the song that we just
that she just released it's not about
the the notoriety was trash you would
have won this card
but you know it would have never been
tried so listen can I just be honest
it's not not trash no it would never be
trash I would never wait wait wait it's
not not trash yeah no anything I got to
do with would not be so you think it's
fresh whether you think it's a five
whether you think about it your song yes
if I'm being honest yeah out of ten yeah
we don't care about out of ten we've
heard worse than what you wish you say
yes this is your first song you've ever
made ever made we don't want to get we
don't want to get the first song I don't
want you to record it like it's like
okay okay I'll give you the critique
right now let's say I had no idea this
was the first song you ever made and I
had no idea that you were involved with
him and you were you came up to me and
you said hey I got a single I want to
play and you play me that song I would
laugh at you and it's it's I would say
it's a steaming pile of dog [__] if I'm
being honest
and then what
the situation in the context of the
situation this is your first song you
ever recorded that's why I said context
is important but just on a song creative
basis
I personally think it's terrible I mean
but he's a man I am a 36 year old
Caucasian who listens to [__] Pusha T
and Griselda and The Roots so this your
song is not for me
[Music]
and guess what when he started to get in
his bag
he came from thousands of miles
but when he went he wasn't in the room
when we're on video and I'm doing images
of the rappers and I was like you know
who's like the most improved rapper
blueface is getting off and I remember
he'd be like bro really and I'd be like
you I mean
I've given you flowers when you weren't
in the room on video where I'm like yo
blueface be saying the flyest it was
[__] and he's in a pocket because when
you first came out I had never you were
so wrong it's kind of like a thing that
people don't understand they don't agree
with you know and I want you to look at
me and just I don't want to offend you
you're not offending
the appeal of your record right now
is you are here's baby mama absolutely
right he's decided to put you on right
and you made a song this is your first
song you ever made so this is very
important because most time People's
First songs that they've ever made never
get heard I know that's obviously I was
just telling her I was like you got 250
000 views in one day I'm like man if I
had that at this very moment your first
song being ever made if I'm judging it
on that scale it's it's cool I I get it
I gotta get my props I'm not mad at
Stewie I like the fact that you guys
went with the Stewie thing
like again it's not for me now you have
tons of improvement because you can't
rap
you're really bad at rapping but you're
gonna get better and for what you guys
are building
I'll it's working 250 000. like I need
you to understand doesn't matter what I
say it's about the market I mean
what he thinks
I want to be honest I think you're a
sweetheart and I think you have a great
head on your shoulders and I'm glad we
had this conversation and I'm glad
people are going to be able to kind of
see more of who you are I think you're
you're rapping this is the first song
you've ever you just decided you know
what's crazy well listen let me finish
you just decided 30 days ago you want to
rap and that's correct so that's why
when I told you if you were to come up
to me and I had zero context about your
whole situation yeah now if you're
telling me 30 days ago I decided I
wanted to rap and a week ago we recorded
this song or two weeks ago we shot I'm
gonna say not hey not bad good job no
what what let me be honest good job let
me ask you this [__] full time
for your first song not that okay let me
ask you this
would you say the same thing did you
make the same observation
I think Christian's rocks music's
[__] god-awful
um so that's not what I'm asking I'm
saying would you have the same
observation I would
again I'm not sure like how long because
you did you convince her to make music
yeah Sam Sammy's act process I think
that
um the roll-up plays more than the music
yes and I think that it so what this is
what I would tell people about music all
the time
the market will determine
what is good or not if people are
watching you you have people's attention
right so all you have to don't worry
about what old white dudes like me say
but yeah it doesn't matter but but
listen no who cares but here we go here
we go no no no but who cares
I I gave you two opinions I gave you the
opinion that if I didn't know who you
were and you walked up to me and you
said hey uh I want you to play my song
on the radio can I play you a song and
you play me that song I gave you that
opinion which would be the full now and
then there's the opinion of I have the
full context of you just started rapping
this is your first song you've ever
recorded uh there's so much on the
contact side where I could be like well
if this is the first time you've ever
recorded a song you are a full-time
mother raising a one-year-old and a
six-year-old absolutely and 30 days ago
you decided to make a song yeah not bad
with the full context I am mad at you so
I got to give you both sides
okay I mean I don't I'm not mad about it
his opinion doesn't like make sure it's
not gonna make her break this is the
thing you'll you have attention so all
that matters is what you do with the
attention okay right so I would tell you
this please if you're gonna do this rap
[__] the next record better be two or
three weeks away
we really want to do this for real
you gotta treat this [__] like a
full-time job you have to stay
consistent okay cool the Stewie video
dropped what's the next move what's the
next one let me start listening to beats
get ideas from him
cool we did a Stewie let's do this and
drop another one you know I think that
that's what I would tell you yeah but
look look that's what we're already on
like I said
I I have a lot of respect for you
because you are raising two kids and
you're literally a full-time Mom this is
what you do you raise children like
dealing with your your six-year-old
you're [__] up his bedroom and not
listening and you recorded a song within
the last 30 days
knowing that I would say hey not bad
keep going
but I told you my opinion if you were
just to come up to me and I didn't know
the [__] you were I can appreciate it I
don't shake it I mean that's uh honestly
personally personally I feel like
even if somebody who came up to you with
the hardest song ever that you didn't
know that was
what makes me careful it would be huh no
it's like what makes you care exactly
that's that's what happened that's what
matters more than the song itself so
right you kind of I feel the same way
somebody could walk up to me tomorrow
with a hit record and if I don't know
nothing about them what makes people
where they from or anything I'm gonna be
like that's cool uh yeah hey good luck I
don't see it yeah so that's honestly a
part of the process and especially in
your world like yeah yeah listen the
people who are those that's more
motivation so you gotta understand
they're coming to you out of curiosity
too because they're like wait blue wait
new face so okay so no I know that it's
a lot of like curiosity because a lot of
the fans are like they came from like a
whole different side because a lot a lot
of fans came from like coming from him
and whatever the [__] else he was doing
yeah yeah and which is great great
whatever can help him is great but
um
I'm not really worried about that listen
it's what I would say my two biggest
things I could tell you is keep going
stay good you got to stay consistent
consistent and that's crazy
and it is very important that you do not
let any of the critiques like the one I
just gave you or the comments bother me
no discouraging discourage is the word
because yeah cause that was crazy it's
Gotta motivate you it's got to motivate
you okay
when I interview him or when I've had
him on my show the people with bro I
can't believe you had that [__]
because the first he's a different
person though right freestyle he ever
did on radio ever was on our show really
really
let me see and listen it when I tell you
the [__] people who texted me that
were appalled that I would even give him
a platform oh yeah guys you guys gotta
[__] chill that's more International
that's more I think it's great I think
it's great I think that he turns every
negative into a positive so I don't
really give a [__] I mean he embraced
the office he's uh he's honestly
teaching me how to turn the negative
into a positive like you do this because
we made this song we made the song right
and he's like what are we calling it
what are we calling I'm like this isn't
that and then I listen to it and I said
Stewie come on come on I'm not playing
I'm not I'm not doing none of this
[__] like what it's like everyone's
hating right come on listen you gotta
turn it up like people automatically are
gonna hate on you because of the
situation whether you're good or bad are
they going to say something but also
with the situation people are just
automatically going to hate on you great
so all you got to do is take that and re
re-channel it into more energy towards
making music yeah I agree
take his advice and listen I I feel like
I really bother
I think you're you seem solid as [__] I
think you know you got a a good woman
here who's you know raise your kids and
uh I hope hey keep dropping music I I
will that's all you gotta do keep
dropping keep dropping absolutely will
hopefully the illegal situation Source
itself appreciate that bro
um do you have anything else coming soon
oh [__] move music Jaden Alexis doing
streaming
uh is it on uh it's about everywhere
everywhere yeah everywhere everywhere so
more music on everything I'm doing up
next is gonna be Jaden Alexis so stay on
the lookout for that and if you're not
on the lookout it's gonna show up on
your timeline
it's too bad so it's no matter what
you're gonna see it you guys so sad it's
gonna be in your head real free baby you
know what y'all should really do figure
out a way to get Drew ski in the next
video
get in the same place that's viral it's
crazy because I was supposed to be at
this party this weekend but I I came
over here so I was like I don't care but
they was telling me come to this party I
was like I'll be there if I'm there but
I come over here take care of you know
blue I gotta cook breakfast you already
know who she is no I mean of course
exactly yeah I think I saw him say
something on Twitter yeah yeah that's
blue face baby
that's my that's my I said whatever
that's my other baby
boss baby mama number three right there
yeah it was funny though I agree it was
funny it was funny I don't
it's hard to it
sir I'm brewed for you I already know
there it is appreciate the sit down guys
yes sir house arrest
boom period fire